[Music]
just recently Martin Scorsese's the
Irishman appeared as a
three-and-a-half-hour Mafia film on
Netflix the focus is now completely on
Scorsese's latest projects killers of
the flower moon which disappeared a bit
during the whole hype around the
Irishman the collider magazine found out
in an interview with Scorsese's camera
man Rodrigo Prieto that they plan to
start shooting killers of the flower
moon in March 2020 at first glance
killers of the flower moon and the
Irishman are relatively similar both are
about a well-known murder story and both
are based on true events the story takes
place in Oklahoma of the 1920s and
revolves around a huge discovery of
crude oil deposits which are however
located under the land of American
natives as you can imagine many of them
are then murdered and the oil rights go
to the farmer William Hale who himself
is behind most of the murders the role
of William Hale will be played by Robert
De Niro while his counterpart from the
FBI will be played by Leonardo DiCaprio
it's also quite possible that they will
again use a digital rejuvenation on the
Niro like in the Irishman
because the real William Hale was in his
40s while De Niro is now 76 years old an
official release date is not yet fixed
but killers of the flower moon will most
likely not be released before the end of
2021 The Rise of the Planet of the Apes
film series is now one of the oldest
franchises at 20th Century Fox and has
been part of Disney since the takeover
as The Hollywood Reporter Reports Maze
Runner director Wes ball will now take
care of it sounds unusual at first after
all Disney is generally considered to be
a very family-friendly company with
corresponding films Rise of the Planet
of the Apes which revolves around a
dystopia in which the monkeys have taken
over control of the earth after a
nuclear war is certainly not one of them
at first glance more details are
unfortunately not yet known
a certain however is that they
definitely have plans for the franchise
however it's not yet clear whether this
will be a reboot or a sequel The Rise of
the Planet of the Apes franchise is
based on a science fiction novel by
Pierre Boulle which was filmed for the
first time in 1968 and became a huge
success thanks to its main character
Charlton Heston number of sequels and
even a TV series followed until in 2001
a rather unsuccessful remake of Tim
Burton appeared for the first time the
last reboot trilogy was with Andy Serkis
s ape Caesar and was quite successful
the extent to which westballz new film
will follow up on this or not is not
certain but of course we will keep you
up-to-date as always for some time now
Todd McFarlane has been developing a
remake of the spawn comics however the
production is currently on hold due to
disagreements over the direction of the
film however MacFarlane seems to think
that the whole thing has become too much
because in a conversation with be
terrific he explains that he has people
who would support him financially in
other words he plays with the idea that
he would shoot the film without the
studio even doubt so it doesn't seem
that much has changed since his last
interview with comic book in May because
even then he declared that his ideas for
the film wouldn't please everyone in
charge moreover he was not willing to
change his original in the way he was
asked to and this despite the fact that
the cast with Jamie Foxx as main hero
and Jeremy Renner as detective twit
Williams was almost certain the story is
about the ex agent L Simmons who's
betrayed and killed by the CIA thereupon
Simmons end up in hell and negotiates a
deal with a demon lord Malick lochia so
that he can see his wife Wanda again he
then returns as spawn gifted with
superpowers and chooses to help the poor
and weak instead of his client from
health the first film adaptation of the
spawn comic was produced for the cinema
in 1997 this resulted in the release of
a cartoon series and even a video game
in
2003 but neither the movie nor the
serious and the game was well received
by fans and critics we are curious when
we will see the movie because if you
believe the words of MacFarlane the
movie will definitely happen with or
without the studio for a long time it
had been quiet around the plant filming
of Hideo Kojima's Metal Gear Solid
series but now there are some good news
from director Jordan [ __ ] Roberts on
Twitter it seems as if things are
progressing behind the scenes he and the
screenwriter
Derek Connolly have also submitted a new
script after the old draft which has
been around since the summer of 2018 was
not too popular but there are also news
regarding the cast including a hot
candidate for the leading role of elite
soldier Solid Snake who exactly this
should be was not revealed but Star Wars
actor Oscar Isaac has already expressed
his interest in the role a few months
ago
what will please many fans of the
videogame series is that Fault Roberts
has once again emphasized that he will
definitely remain true to the original
the script is supposed to be full of
Kojima peculiarities and military
surrealism when we can expect a film
unfortunately it's not yet certain at
the moment hardly anyone is currently as
much in demand in Hollywood as Keanu
Reeves
he's currently involved in three
projects John wick for matrix 4 and Bill
and Ted faced the music a pretty big
burden for the 55 year old as his John
wig colleague Lance Reddick also says
who reveals in an interview on
comicbook.com that there is still no
script for John week 4 furthermore he
says that although they are working on
writing a script it is not that easy
because Keanu Reeves is still committed
to two other movies or OVA he's not sure
whether metrics for up John week four
will come next
radek's not wrong as the shooting of
metrics for is scheduled for the
beginning of next year while ken Reeves
is probably fully scheduled for the
promotion of Bill and Ted face the music
in mid 2020 which would result in
various travels and interviews so when
John week four arrives will depend on
how quickly a script and
thus the shooting schedule is completed
so far the us-american release date is
May 21 in 2021 but should there still be
no shooting schedule in a few months
time the release will certainly be
delayed quite a bit
[Music]